all right i'm going to squat down a
little bit um so uh today i'm uh mine so
just to start my name is eric sammer i'm
one of the engineering managers at
cloudera
i run two of the teams uh within
clutter's engineering group uh one of
which is building the clutter developer
kit or the the cdk which is uh what i'm
gonna talk about uh talk about tonight
um
before i sort of dive into that you know
one of this this is a quote that came
out of uh
one of the gentlemen i know this guy
arun jacob who runs uh
disney's
internal data platform team
it was an interesting quote it was you
know it's not enough to build a scalable
and stable system system also be easy
enough for thousands of internal
developers and uh to be able to use
um and i think that this is something
that
you know uh we've had the the sort of
dubious honor of seeing a cloudera
clutter has a couple hundred different
customers and different verticals and
things like that and one of the things
that we see a lot
is you know different different skill
levels for different developers coming
from different backgrounds uh lots of
sort of standard java middleware
developers i think a lot of the same
people that terence was talking about
earlier that might not be sort of deep
distributed systems people uh or data
management people but might be people
who know things like spring and tomcat
and sort of like traditional jms and
java middleware
um so we really wanted to make this this
entire platform hadoop and all of its
related ecosystem components a little
bit more accessible to to the the sort
of standard enterprise java community
um so i think when we look at it we say
like sure hadoop is is really powerful
let you work with all the different file
formats now with things like yarn uh
systems like uh application uh developer
kits like weave you can build all these
sort of newfangled data or oriented or
distributed applications
and in a lot of ways hadoop is is really
really flexible it lets you get away
with all kinds of different things um
just as a side effect of
the different sort of abstractions that
it gives you
unfortunately what we've seen is that
hadoop is also really low level
for a lot of people who have written and
just by show of hands how many of you
have written a mapreduce job using the
plain jane java mapreduce apis yeah so
so it's enough enough hands that go up
and and they kind of go up with that
sort of post-traumatic stress disorder
like yes i've i've survived this it was
terrible but i did it uh and all i got
was this t-shirt type of thing so you
know to even implement the simplest
things of like a relational join
um or you know basic filtering
application this stuff is pretty low
level um and i don't think that i'm i'm
uh i'm uh breaking any truce by by
talking about that
and as a result and much like everything
that terence just described hadoop is
incredibly complex
as a side effect of being a distributed
system it's much harder to build a
quote-unquote hadoop application or a
data pipeline or uh you know a back-end
distributed system on top of hadoop than
it is to build a system on mysql right
you know it's just by definition more
complex
with all these different moving parts
um so this is this is my eye chart we're
going to start here i think when most
people talk about like the typical
application or the typical system that
people build on top of hadoop it's very
commonly uh and most of you probably
can't see this um which is kind of the
point is that when you when you when an
architect stands up at a white board and
says we're going to build a hadoop
application it's going to be great and
you know don't worry about it life is
going to be good this is kind of what
they draw on the whiteboard they say
there's going to be a web application
that web application is going to spit
out a bunch of events like user activity
data or click
transactions metric information
application performance metric
information things like that
we're going to take that event data and
we're going to collect it into a big
bucket called event data and then we're
going to run like maybe an hourly job or
a job that runs every 15 minutes where
we calculate some billing information
and we're going to build a reporting
data set that you know we use to drive
you know relational database system or
you know business intelligence
application or build recommendations and
this is this is the application dear
java developers go build it right
but when you think about it it's it's a
little bit more involved right when you
look at that web application you've got
the servlet and then you've got this log
for j appender or an slf uh for j
appender and you've got to figure out
how you're actually going to transport
that event data from that web
application into the the repository of
like where these events eventually need
to land and in the world of hadoop and i
assume that most of you care about
hadoop that's probably some a file
system like hdfs um
and you might look at a system like
flume i'm a little bit biased on one of
the flume committers uh but it could be
kafka it could be you know whatever
makes the most sense to you
you got to figure out how all that works
and transport events over into hdfs
then you've got to worry about the
mapreduce layer and building that sort
of job that's going to run once an hour
every 15 minutes or whatever it is
you then need to maybe you pick sql and
you say i'm a sql developer i'm going to
use hive to to author my mapreduce jobs
because i have ptsd from writing you
know
mapreduce jobs uh by hand
so you decide you're gonna do that and
then you say well now i need a scheduler
a workflow engine to drive this to make
sure that it runs every hour or every 15
minutes so you've got like all of these
different pieces
um
and
you know that's that's sort of the next
layer of like zooming into the system
but of course that's not it either right
so that's what the typical job developer
writes out in their sort of design dock
or whatever but when you get into the
nuts and bolts of the system what you
realize is
well
you actually need to worry about the
structure of the events that you're
going to log or am i going to use text
records and worry about parsing them
down the road when i get them into hdfs
or am i going to use a structured format
like
got help us json or
or avro or thrift or protocol buffers
then how do i make flume understand my
avro format events how do i deal with
things like file durability or delivery
durability how do i get that data
partitioned maybe i want to partition
that data set because it's too big uh in
hdfs
you know there's there's you just sort
of keep ballooning out as you zoom into
these systems
and at the end of the day the only part
you really care about
and the only part that your company
really cares about is getting the data
from a to b
probably in the right format and using
it later
everything else is just in between you
and your paycheck or you and your
caltrain home whatever it is
but you know you have these
serialization file format problems what
compression codec are you going to use
metadata capture maintenance of you have
all these sort of things that you know
uh i i wouldn't say this back at
clutter's home office but the relational
database community has figured this out
for the last 30 years right you need
scheme evolution you need metadata
tracking you need administrative tools
for managing that you need partitioning
you need compression you need the proper
on disk format yada yada yada
so all of these you know and then you've
got sort of the distributed
systems aspect you've got the delivery
mechanics the failure mechanics the data
durability semantics um failure
semantics and sort of how things break
down you you almost certainly want
performance and health instrumentation
of all these different components it's a
lot to think about it's a lot to worry
about
so we looked at this and we said at the
end of the day
this is the difference between the toy
application that the terence talked
about like all of this stuff
um and
uh
sorry i don't mean to imply terence is
talking strictly about toy applications
what i mean is that when you know when
we're referring to a toy application
sort of your hadoop 101 i can get a text
record from a web app into hdfs that's
like the first 10 percent of what you
need to do the other 90
is all the mechanics that surround that
right so the the production sort of
beefing up of failure scenarios and all
this other stuff that terence was
describing in the yarn world also apply
sort of at the macro level all these
different services
so we look at this and we kind of say
you know as cloudera this is the thing
that prevents us
from
prevents you from adopting hadoop as a
platform
and you know quite frankly that cuts
into our bottom line we don't like that
right we want hadoop to be easy to use
easy to build these sort of large-scale
data-oriented applications on top of
so
this is also sort of self-serving in the
sense that like we have a field
technical services of a hundred plus
people that do this over and over and
over again for various customers so we
really wanted to do is build a kit of
various libraries
and apis
that make these types of applications a
little bit easier to do
and it's worth stating since you know
terence just gave this sort of really
cool presentation around weave and with
what continuity is doing on on yarn
it's worth pointing out that what
everything i'm going to talk about is um
is mostly on the data management and
ingest and sort of management side it's
completely compatible if you wanted to
use something like weave on the compute
side so we're not really tackling the
compute problem because we know that
other people are
so what we decided to do is to make
these apis and really take a lot of the
expertise and the sort of expert
patterns for distributed systems for
data management and sort of bake them
into code as much as possible behind
some really simple sort of easy to use
api so you'll see a lot of similarity in
what i'm describing for this problem
domain as what what terence described on
the yarn side
we really wanted to make the quote
unquote right thing easy to do
so we know for instance that
ninety percent of the people
that write data into hadoop do it in
text format and then regret like 100
regret it later you know nobody wants
that at the end of the day um it's
really big it's just a nightmare to deal
with you get into compression codecs
that these ones are splittable and
that's not splittable and there's rc
file and there's parquet and there's
avro and there's protobuf and there's
all this other stuff and most people go
like i really don't care i just want to
get data into hdfs and query it via hive
or impala or process it with my new
fancy weave application you know most
people don't care about the stuff so we
really wanted to make the right thing
easy to do and just obvious we wanted to
be the default we wanted to fix the
defaults if you will and we really
wanted to focus on the most common use
cases and i'll use this ingest like
event data into a big bucket process it
refine it into a different smaller
bucket then you serve it downstream with
other systems
we really wanted you guys to be able to
focus on the application logic and i
want to focus on the application logic
you know
uh unfortunately clutter pays me to do
the infrastructure work so um
so that's what i'm stuck with it's not
really a bad gig um we're hiring as well
so
it could be your bag gig as well
um
well i got to entertain myself as well
up here i give this presentation all the
time so um and much like you know j2ee
and that's probably a dirty word for
some of you and your lifeblood for the
other half of you you know uh j2e
especially servlets
took apart these two things right you
don't want to worry about multi-threaded
development and http as a protocol and
you know all the various other you know
request response mechanics and
deployment you really want to build the
little five lines of code that you
actually need to do to serve like a
velocity template or something like that
so that's really where we sort of want
to be
so the clutter development kit or the
cdk because i'll get tired of calling it
the clutter development kit really fast
is an open source set of libraries
it's apache license so it's completely
compatible with the rest of the hadoop
ecosystem
it's up on github i'll give you some
pointers later
and it's really a set of libraries
guides examples for building these sort
of data oriented distributed systems
oriented applications and it definitely
and completely builds on existing apis
that uh in my world that's cdh um rather
than replacing so so like taran said you
know weave doesn't replace yarn the cdk
doesn't replace
hdfs mapreduce flume kafka any of these
other things it's a thin veneer on top
of that to make life a little bit easier
we really wanted to focus on this notion
of piecemeal adoption because not
everybody uses hbase we don't want to
force hbase on you not everybody wants
hive we're not going to force hive on
you so we want you to be able to pick
and choose the parts that you like and
make sense for your application
um
so
we set out to build like a different a
set of modules for lack of a better you
know thing to call them and each module
is sort of a self-contained
uh set of apis that kind of work
together for some specific problem
domain
the first thing that i always jump up
and down about and screaming yell about
is getting data into hadoop in the right
way and there kind of is a right way and
yes you can do text and you have that
flexibility and we're not going to take
that away from you that said it's almost
certainly not what you want you almost
certainly care about things about like
partitioning
uh compression
metadata management all these other
things i was talking about earlier so
the first module we built we just called
uh very charmingly the data module
and really what this is is a set of apis
for interacting with logical data sets
in hdfs so if you're using hdfs we
wanted to give you a higher level
construct than files and directories
because
really
like the relational database wraps all
of this other information around the
notion of a table it has schema it has
evolution semantics it has you know uh
various guarantees in terms of how it
works we wanted to give you the same
thing on top of hdfs
um
we really wanted things like file format
partitioning information and schema
management to be configuration driven
rather than code driven we don't want
people sort of manipulating the level
bits we want people worrying about sort
of higher level logical
abstractions we wanted to give a
consistent data model that all of the
tools would understand and be compatible
with so that you don't have to say well
hive supports rc file but pig doesn't
and if i use h catalog well then maybe
this other thing none of that matters to
you nobody cares about that i mean we
care about that uh we want to care about
that for you
um keeping track of things like metadata
integration with uh either third-party
systems or
sort of de facto standards that are
cropping up in the hadoop world like age
catalog is one of those standards you
might not care about age catalog
specifically
you might not know what it's called but
i'll guarantee you want its
functionality
so we want to give that to you for free
wherever we can
and like i said things like partitioning
and management of that you know we
really wanted to make that as simple as
possible so uh in the interest of of
showing you you know some of the the
meat behind it um again you'll see a lot
of the similar sort of fluent
builder-oriented apis that are a little
bit easier to deal with so on the left
here i have an example of using the data
module apis
to
create
and write a bunch of events to a
partitioned data set
on the right i have the result that will
materialize on hdfs
there's a couple of things that we've
done here that are particularly tricky
one we make sure that the partitioning
is the partition format that's going to
work with hive impala and everything
else that understands sort of that
hadoop de facto partitioning scheme
we work with a file format and sort of
abstract the the nuts and bolts that's
going to work for ninety percent of your
use cases and if you're smarter then by
all means use the trapdoor and sort of
build your own sort of format
plug-in but in reality the defaults are
the right thing for most of you and yes
all data is compressed all the time what
if i don't want it compressed then you
can dig into the trap door but most of
the time you do so it's that way by
default so up at the top we have this
notion of a data set repository which is
a slightly different name for a database
it's a collection of data sets
that all sort of generally want you want
to live together or have the same
attributes or the same usage patterns
there's a plugin that specifically
understands hdfs and the local file
system called the file system data set
repository and again it's got a nice
builder
and basically the way it works is that
you supply a hadoop file system
implementation and we handle all of the
guts around laying data out in that file
system for you you just give us a root
directory and we sort of take over from
there the same way hbase you give it a
root directory and it takes over from
there
um
so in this case we're using the root
directory slash data for no no other
good reason then it was easy to type
from that data set repository
we create data sets and when you create
a data set you give it a name and you
give it a data set descriptor
and that descriptor specifies things
like the partition strategy which again
has a nice builder you can do things
like hash partitioning or identity
partitioning range partitioning whatever
makes most sense
and we define all schemas in terms of
avro schemas the on disk representation
might not be avro but we give you one
schema definition language and we handle
what that materializes uh to be on the
file system because
you know again for for lack of a a
better
alternative avro has
reasonable apis for describing schemas
and we were able to we had a committer
who's on the cdk team who kind of went
like hey we can get you know better
fixes and do avro so we did that
once you have a data set in hand this is
the equivalent of a table
all records in that data set will sort
of look the same they'll have the same
schema
and that schema can be as simple as it's
got one field and it's called text
and it's just a big string or it can be
as complex as a binary array that
represents a jpeg image
automatically compressed automatically
accessible via mapreduce and all this
other stuff
from this we uh we let you uh create and
grab a handle to a writer and you simply
write avro records again in memory we
always describe these things as avro
well actually you have your options
there are either java pojos an
avrogeneric record or a generated avro
avro class
under the hood we do the right
serialization
and you can just here i'm showing a
generic average generic record
you pack your data into it you flush the
writer
however you want and you close it on the
right hand side you see the resultant
data that would materialize on hdfs
we don't show it here but there are
different what we call metadata
providers that let you plug into
different metadata systems and that can
be things like h catalog or it can be in
this case we actually just store the
metadata on the file system alongside
the data set in a hidden directory so we
serialize the descriptor properties and
the actual original avro schema so that
when we load that data set you don't
have to provide us the avro schema we
can load it from the metadata provider
and if that metadata provider is age
catalog
which is purely a configuration problem
all of the data sets you read and write
using these apis are immediately
available to hive and tools that
understand the hive metastore including
impala which you know cloudera users
care a lot about
so this lets you do sort of really fancy
things where you can write data and
switch terminals and immediately query
it which is really really nice
so we handle partitioning and again if
you've used hive and you understand
highest partitioning model
this makes a lot of sense to you
although i don't know that you ever want
to partition by hash of user id but
there's a good example
one of the other modules so that's the
data apis it's just sort of a whirlwind
tour
and what you'll find is one of the
things that we do with these apis is
we know that nobody reads documentation
so
our uh let's just be serious about it
like no one reads it i wrote the apis
and the docs and i never read them so
one thing that we realized is that
developers um the documentation they use
is the auto complete in their ide
like you type a dot and whatever the
next set of methods that appear those
are the ones you call right so we really
wanted that level of accessibility to
some of these some of these apis so if
you're if you're like me you can't be
bothered switching to your web browser
to look at the docs we sort of we we
sort of abide by this ide auto complete
documentation
one of the other modules that we built
was a system called morph lines it's
just a library
and really what it is is it's plugable
configuration driven
record level transformation so if you
have a stream of records that you simply
need to rip apart and reformat uh from
various formats and apply various
processing to morph lines is your thing
uh this actually came out of cloudera
search so we cut our recently uh
added search to our repertoire which is
you know solar with some nuts and bolts
packed onto it and one of the use cases
that everybody wants in search is that
they have a stream of data coming in
from
you know scribe or flume or kafka or
whatever
and as records arrive you want to shove
them into solar in in real time so that
they're immediately queryable by the by
the search system
and maybe you want to send another copy
to hdfs for analysis or transformation
but what we found was that people were
getting text records in but they really
knew that they wanted to tear that
record apart and extract the date and
they wanted to extract the severity of
the log message and they wanted to do
this sort of in-line transformation
so morph lines uh was exactly that and
what the search guys had done was they
embedded it inside of flume so that as
events were passing through flume during
data collection they could be sort of
torn apart in real time and indexed as
sort of uh you know higher order events
so that's what morph lines is really
built for we've realized that this was
useful in many other cases not just the
clutter search case so we decided to
make it a library
for users of things like logstash or
splunk this probably sounds pretty
familiar
so you can configure these
transformation stages and you have this
sort of container
if you're familiar with like a chain of
responsibility pattern that's basically
all morph lines is
you can use this as a library inside of
flume mapreduce job storm
you know any other weave applications
doesn't matter you can embed it wherever
you want
um
and plain old java applications that are
totally unrelated to to uh this
particular platform
there's a bunch of other modules and i
don't have time to go into all of them
um
we built like a maven plug-in which lets
you do sort of uh automatic packaging of
your quote-unquote big data applications
deployment to hdfs um excuse me and sort
of the ability to execute
these um
processing pipelines
um
we also give you the ability to do sort
of uh
for rails users they're used to having
things like data migrations where part
of the build actually migrates you know
the schema over time we give you the
ability to do that with
cdk data sets
there's also a huge module full of
examples just
various examples that you can take
customize
use outright do whatever you want with
things like
taking pojos generic records and
generated entities or records or events
and just ingesting them to hadoop in
various ways partition non-partition so
on and so forth
data set administration
administrative operations so if you want
to build
sort of custom tooling around schema
viewing and stuff like that
we have crunch and mapreduce integration
with all these data sets um and various
other pieces of the platform
um
we realize that this is sort of the tip
of the iceberg and really our goal is to
build out sort of this real rich high
level easy to use set of apis
there's a lot of stuff i didn't talk
about obviously hbase is a huge topic
we're actually in the process right now
of of integrating sort of a really nice
hbase layer that has all of the right
scheme evolution
stuff on top of it that is compatible
with hbase's flexible schema model
that handles row key sorting in the
right way if you don't want to deal with
mem comparable you know lexigraphic sort
water and all this other nonsense
and all those other sort of higher level
features
we want to do a bunch of stuff with
higher order data management you can
think about common tasks that you have
to do with data sets things like
background compaction of many many files
or automatic file format conversion or
you know background conversion things
like that
we might do things like
libraries for data set exclusive
read shared and exclusive locks
for data in hdfs because sometimes you
you do want to actually lock data sets
so we would build like the hadoop
equivalent of flock for those of you who
are familiar with that
integration with existing middleware
frameworks so there's systems out there
like spring batch and pentaho and all
these other things that you might also
use
but by all means please give us your
your good ideas you can keep the bad
ones but but please give us your good
ideas uh as well as your code um
uh so
if you want to sort of get started again
just like weave this is this is
available on on github it's apache
license you can take it do whatever you
want with it
so github.com clutter cdk
uh there's also a
cdk-examples repo that you can take and
do all sorts of fun and exciting stuff
with
um we also have binary source and
documentation artifacts in cloudera's
maven repo so if you use cdh you go in
and you create a maven dependency and
you automatically get all the right
stuff
there's community.cloudera.com that has
forums
people like me and
other folks on the cdk team will be
answering questions there's a mailing
list if you prefer email if you don't
have enough email we can add to that
pile for you
or if you want to file jiras and tell us
we got it wrong please please feel free
to do to do that
and with that i'm happy to take
questions that that that people have
yeah
oh it's a good question so the question
is how does how does this sort of the
data set partitioning stuff fit into
flume
right so flume provides
um very basic understanding and it's
mostly the same thing right it's mostly
flume's bucketing support which is what
we called it in flume
it's the ability to inspect an
individual record extract a couple of
pieces uh from that and then decide you
know how to parameterize the file system
laid out the right way so basically
there's a little slice of flume that
i've always wanted to be able to use in
different applications so this data set
api is actually like a slice of that
lifted out of flume and made into a
nicer api there's a couple of other
things that flume does under the hood
that are kind of specific to flume
and a couple things it doesn't do
that
you probably want it to do if you were
to use its partitioning support
outside of flume itself so flume doesn't
actually have any knowledge of
um
you know structured events it has like a
key value pair map of headers and then a
binary blob
is its body and you have to do a bunch
of trickery to extract pieces of the
event into the headers before you can do
bucketing in reality
um
what this is is a cleaner way to do to
do a lot of that
and flume only supports
like identity partitioning so taking an
exact value out of the header and plug
it into the path what we found is that
people wanted to do fancier things like
apply this function
to a field to get a value and then
partition by that value which is
basically like hash partitioning and
stuff like that
so if you wanted to do ranges or any
sort of complex partitioning scheme you
kind of have to do some funky stuff um
so so that part is much easier there's
also mechanics around the durability
like flume very specifically is managing
file handles and in this case you we
want to give you the ability to handle
you know uh well actually under the hood
we handle things like how many file
handles do you keep open while you're
sort of binning data and recycling those
file handles and doing all the the magic
that for better or worse we need to do
because of the you know the hdfs append
only semantics
yeah yeah that's a great question the
follow-up question of course is why
doesn't why don't we just build a flume
sync that sort of wraps the data set
apis and sort of does the right thing
and gives you this the shorter answer is
it's absolutely a jira that's sitting on
on my to-do list
today
if you look at the examples what we do
is we line up
the partition scheme and flume's
bucketing
to be identical and you know sort of
make sure that they line up because at
least today it's possible to get it
wrong and i don't like that right
because it people will right and people
do you know they get everything wrong um
there's also like stuff like what do you
do if flume is missing the header like
avro actually gives you reasonable sport
about defaults and unions and all this
other stuff
uh good question so are we exposing
cloudera manager apis on this the short
answer is no and i'm going to tell you a
dirty secret no one's allowed to repeat
it outside of this room
um
nothing in the cdk today is cloudera
specific
and that's very much by design at least
for today
we don't want anything
to
require
you be running clutter manager at least
not today so if you just run cdh or and
i don't know why you would if you run
some other hadoop distribution i don't
test the latter but there's a good
chance it just works so there's no
clutter specific stuff in it
in fact we're thinking of renaming it
specifically for that to sort of
indicate to the world that it's not just
clutter that said
the clutter manager team has actually
built some reasonable java apis on top
of the the clutter manager the cm api
that make life a little bit easier
there's actually another git repo if you
sort of poke around under the cloud air
space there on github where you'll
you'll find that um
so
i don't know that we'll never do it but
if there were a reason because this is
like the clutter managers like almost
exclusively for the operations folks
like the devops guys and stuff like that
this is almost exclusively for the you
know i build servlets i build data
applications i build you know data
pipelines uh community they tend to be
different if they weren't different i
don't know maybe we emerged them at some
point
yes
i'm not going to repeat the question
because
um the short answer is is that there's
always stuff going on with clutter as a
company
um tonight i kind of have at least while
i'm up here my clutter salesman hat off
and i i'm happy to talk about that stuff
offline but i really want to just focus
on the developer stuff up here yeah
oh do we actually use the cdk yeah
absolutely so
we eat our own dog food very much on a
lot of this stuff so
if you're like a paying cloudera
customer and you've paid for like
professional services
um it might not be called the cdk it
might be called com.myawesome company
you know but these apis and this code
may actually be in use at various places
so it is actually used in a number of
different places and we're talking to a
number of these other sort of
hadoop ecosystem specific
framework guys um and i won't name names
because nothing's final about using this
as their hadoop integration support
so you might see this appear in various
other places where the cdk as a project
is relatively young
um we started it in like march of this
year
um
well that's when the first release was
it was started before that um and we're
doing monthly releases right now so
we're actually moving very very quickly
so things are changing very very quickly
uh
not on the apis but just on like the
scope of the project the people who are
interested in it
certainly we use it very much internally
um there's a bunch of our customers that
already use it in various ways and we've
actually started getting like community
you know pull requests on github from
people we've never heard of which i
think is a good sign right you know
people just randomly going like here's
the thing i did you have no idea who i
am you know and please take it um
uh once we work out the licensing you
know we pull that in um so we're happy
to take uh you know contributions that
way as well
uh so the short answer is yes um there's
one customer in particular that
processes a couple terabytes per hour
that pass through the cdk
any other questions
in the back
yeah
you did mention that it is exposed to
the outside world as our low interface
yeah so
by default it's that we actually store
in avro
because we care very much about impala
as a side effect we care very much about
parquet which is a new columnar format
that cloudera and twitter and a couple
other people have been sort of
collaborating on
also open source it's a columnar form
now we can talk about difference between
row and column and all that stuff but
there's actually a flag that you pass
when you create a data set in the data
set descriptor and you say
i want my data in parquet you know
to be sort of easily queryable
or more performant under under impala
and we
you still your application still uses
avro in memory and then on disk we
actually write parquet data the right
way
we're talking about and i'm reluctant to
do it i'd really love to hear people's
opinions on it about whether or not we
actually support
read it like fully support text as an
underlying format
i
am reluctant to make it any easier for
people to write new text data into
hadoop but i recognize that people
already have text data in hadoop so it's
not an option that we expose today it's
easily
done but
so today it's just available
my follow-up parque is the hour of words
to advantage what is the schema which
goes with uh
data
and another one
so when you transfer some internal form
and how are you dealing with those
so we actually maintain the data uh in
memory completely until it's actually
serialized uh so it stays in avro format
until it actually winds up being avro on
disk where there's zero copy uh if
you're using a generic well if you're
using a generated uh record
um
or in the case of parquet there's a copy
to parquet's internal format but there's
a
you can represent
almost
every almost every other
schema structure
with avro's schema language everything
else is a subset because avro supports
all kinds of wacky stuff
in reality you can support
the the sort of relational subset of
like you know
columns and and rows and types and then
sort of default you know columns with
defaults and the ability to modify that
schema so uh
you know at the end of the day
everything winds up being a subset of
avro's sort of description of a data set
so it's pretty easy to convert that uh
under the hood i don't know if that's a
actually an answer to the question you
asked or my interpretation but
close close enough all right good enough
close enough is excellent it's a good
place to be
okay
cool thank you guys so much